oh my
God hi I'm Michael Hitchcock and I'm
Katherine Greenwood and we are in the
movie Xmas and today we are going to
partake in a Christmas gift wrapping
competition I'm already sweating my
Palms me
too ooh
pretty
ooh
oh hey I want some of the ribbon I want
one of the fancy curly ones too
hex he's Tex me I can't do this come on
it's not opening up psychologically it's
working okay now how do you wrap a star
doesn't matter just wrap the baby my
thing
broke too bad for you Catherine green is
the hex this is not
fair wow yours is actually really
goodful it's like a a talented
seven-year-old made this
[Music]
a stuffed goat look at that a goat
okay this is basically Christmas Eve at
my house so oh a you do a you're going
to win again I'm not happy this looks
like a delicious Christmas candy I know
I would I'd choose that
one thank
you
all right now now now this is rigged Mar
three
[Music]
marbles oh you're doing each one
individually well yeah but I'm doing
this like it looks like fun and then
when they open it up and they've only
got three marbles they're not going to
love
it how nice it looks it's really nice it
looks like a little like a turtle got
stuck in a I actually like this though
and mine looks really pretty if I keep
my thumb on it I would just like to say
I never win things because I don't
participate in competitions and so I'm
very happy to win this oh toilet mug oh
that's a mug that's disgusting I had one
day on set where I was a little runny I
could have used something like this well
that's what happens you know and you're
all right AG done set this is the end of
the night end of Christmas Eve you're
exhausted kids are going to wake up in
about 15 minutes
wrapping
sh that's really nice it's creative well
they get a whole ribbon with the toilet
book oh thank you
uhoh what oh oh my God okay oh my
God all
right I feel bad doing this to this okay
there we go well this is not good oh oh
no this is a nightmare now where did I
put the tape this is where you see me
give up cuz that's the kind of person I
am mine you're much better yours is
awesome no it really oh for God Sak that
it's too much for me to the anxiety
Merry Christmas Michael oh here's
something for you thank you I wonder
what this could be I don't know I have
no idea that's a teddy bear a this is
something I need cuz I live in
Canada yep wow story
life if you watch xus you're going to
feel like a winner just like me even if
you're a loser just like me oh you're
not a loser Catherine thank you Michael
you just came in
[Music]
last